und in Berlin begrüße ich die Grünen
verteidigungsexpertin an jeschka Brucker
guten Abend
bevor wir über die Qualifikation des
neuen weitersprechen wie wichtig war und
ist es das gleich viele Frauen und
Männer in dieser Regierung sind
dass Frauen und Männer auch gut im
Kabinett repräsentiert sind und auch
gleich im Kabinett repräsentiert das ist
nicht nur ein Anliegen das den Grünen
wichtig ist sondern dass der Kanzler ja
auch selber vorgetragen hat und deshalb
waren wir natürlich schon sehr irritiert
dass es jetzt auch zum zweiten Mal
eigentlich so ist das auch die SPD
diesen Anspruch nicht erfüllt und das
kann nicht sein dass die Parität immer
noch von den Grünen im Kabinett
eingehalten wird deshalb hätten wir uns
natürlich schon gewünscht dass diese
Frage auch berücksichtigt worden wäre
nun hätte es ja auch eine größere
Kabinettsumbildung sein können hätte man
das da vielleicht leichter realistischer
bewerkstelligen können
am Ende entscheidet natürlich jede
Partei und über die und natürlich auch
der Bundeskanzler selbst über ihre
eigenen Ressorts und unabhängig von der
Frage der Parität und auch anderer
Fragen die möglicherweise auf dem Tisch
liegen könnten kann ich auch nur sagen
dass ich mich trotzdem sehr auf die
Zusammenarbeit mit Boris Pistorius freue
und dass ich ihn für eine exzellente
Wahl im Amt das Verteidigungsministers
halte dann sprechen wir noch mal über
ihn was glauben Sie wie kommt der bei
den Soldatinnen und Soldaten an
die ersten Reaktionen die ich heute so
gelesen und gesehen habe die mich
erreicht haben waren erstmal durchweg
positiv und ich glaube es ist wirklich
ein sehr erfahrener Minister der auch ja
mit im Bereich der inneren Sicherheit
natürlich mehr als nur Berührungspunkte
mit den Themen der äußeren Sicherheit
hatte selbst ja persönlich eine große
Verbundenheit zur Bundeswehr zum
Ausdruck gebracht hat und es sind
wirklich sehr schwierige Zeiten es ist
ein extrem schwieriges Ressort und ich
glaube mit dieser Erfahrung mit dem
ansehen dass er hat bringt er durchaus
auch sehr wichtige Qualifikation mit ja
sie haben gerade angedeutet bisher hatte
man bei der Bundeswehr oft das Gefühl
alles dauert unglaublich lange
Beschaffung Erneuerung wie muss
historisch jetzt vorgehen
wir brauchen jetzt einen
Verteidigungsminister der anpackt die
über Jahre entstandenen und vor allem
liegengebliebenen Probleme der nicht
viel Show macht sondern der insbesondere
dafür sorgt dass wir in zeitenwurf
unserem Kontinent ein brutaler
russischer Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine tobt eine Bundeswehr haben die
gut aufgestellt ist die gut ausgestattet
ist die motiviert ist und die im Bündnis
ihrer Verantwortung wahrnehmen kann da
gibt es im Bereich der Beschaffung im
Bereich des Materials des Personals
große Herausforderung aber natürlich
wird es auch darum gehen in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten Sicherheitspolitik
gemeinsam mit den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern zu diskutieren in einen echten
Dialog zu treten und da habe ich ihn
auch immer sehr geschätzt als ein
Politiker der eine sehr klare
Kommunikation pflegt auch das ist extrem
wichtig
auch in seiner Partei also der SPD
preist man ihn ja generalsekten Kühnert
hat gesagt er habe ihn als beherzten
Anpacker und Problemlöser kennengelernt
ist das genau das was die Bundeswehr
jetzt braucht
ja wir haben ja wirklich viele
Verteidigungsminister und innen aus der
Union gesehen wenn sie an karl-Theodor
zu Gutenberg denken unfassbar viel Show
aber eigentlich hat er den ja Grundstein
gelegt für viele Probleme die uns heute
einholen oder denken Sie an Ursula von
der Leyen die eben auch zwar immer
wieder Probleme sehr
öffentlichkeitswirksam angesprochen hat
viel Wirbel erzeugt hat und dann sind
aber die entscheidenden Fragen liegen
geblieben deshalb braucht es jetzt
jemanden der sehr solide sehr schnell
anpackt und zukunftsfeste Strukturen für
die Bundeswehr ermöglicht die
Chronologie der Vorgängerinnen und
Vorgänge ist ja noch viel viel länger
wir haben gestern schon über Herrn
sharping gesprochen wir haben über viele
PolitikerInnen Politiker gesprochen für
die das Amt offenbar eine Nummer zu groß
war aber das befürchten sie in diesem
Fall nicht
ich freue mich auf jeden Fall auf eine
gute Zusammenarbeit für die Anliegen der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten für eine kluge
Sicherheitspolitik und es ist in der Tat
das schwierigste Ressort man ist
verantwortlich für unfassbar viele
Menschen man hat auch eine hohe
Verantwortung für die sehr schwierigen
Fragen von Kriegen und Frieden und eine
Sache würde ich uns allen trotzdem ein
bisschen selbstkritischen mit auf den
Weg geben worden
Weg geben gerade in diesem Amt ist es in
den letzten Jahren oft so gewesen dass
der kleinste Fehler der im
Beschaffungsamt passiert ist oder auch
ein großer Fehler sofort immer auf den
Minister die Ministerin hochgesst wurde
ich glaube da muss man auch ein bisschen
anders fair miteinander umgehen
natürlich Probleme auch in der
entsprechenden Deutlichkeit ansprechen
aber wir sollten gerade in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten auch gemeinsam
schauen wie wir diese Herausforderungen
gerade für die Menschen in der
Bundeswehr gemeinsam anpacken sagt die
Grünen verteidigungs-
vielen Dank